[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday May 17th
Banerjee birthday happy birthday
Katherine got three and it's your
birthday that's right it's Katherine
greens birthday have you Earth Day
Katherine we're the same age again every
year for 12 days we are different ages
and it just throws me completely off no
it doesn't it doesn't really anyway I
have to do this video quickly because
Katherine has birthday needs to attend
to for example we're having a party
tonight and I'd rather she didn't have
to clean the house in preparation for
the party that would just be lame to
have to clean up for your own birthday
party so Katherine doesn't know what
she's getting yet aside from my France
themed birthday party so I can't
actually tell you what she's getting
because she's going to watch this before
she gets it and that would ruin the
surprise
I'm excited about the party but we have
some other things to attend to first
as for the proposed book proposals I
have no idea how to write a book
proposal for a fiction book right now
all I have is stories in my head and
they're getting better and funner and
more like cool and sort of intense so
I'm excited about that but you know how
do you propose fiction do you like make
the list of characters and propose
situations and talk about I don't know
it's it's a mystery to me I need your
help I feel like it's something that you
must know maybe you've even done that
before second wiki the word wiki is a
word for a collaborative website and it
is pronounced Wiki Wikipedia is a mix of
the words wiki and encyclopedia if the
mix occurred at the a pedia and the wick
then you would have Wikipedia but the
mix occurs after wiki and then PDF so
you have wiki pedia I am right about
this I've been wrong about many things
in my life once during a presentation on
the Renaissance a pronounced facade the
Kade I was wrong but a
Wikipedia I am right I went to the
Wikipedia page on Wikipedia and if
Wikipedia is right about anything it's
right about itself pronunciations of
Wikipedia include Wikipedia and
Wikipedia those are the two
pronunciations of Wikipedia at Wikipedia
not Wikipedia Wikipedia there were
people in the comments who were changing
the way that they pronounce Wikipedia
because you were wrong in fact they have
a button you can click to hear someone
pronouncing the word Wikipedia and that
person pronounces it Wikipedia I mean
this is an interesting side effect of
text based communication when you only
read words you never find out how
they're actually pronounced but because
we're not using text-based communication
anymore I get to find out when you're
wrong unless I can correct you and rub
your face all in it so say with me John
wiki pedia I'll see you tomorrow